the days go why but the grief is still
hard beer
bodies keep arriving at this church in
Northern Iraq
for Tuesday's wedding fire that killed
more than 100 people
a saying we inherited from our ancestors
goes we were happily gathered until the
storm dispersed us now we say we were
happily gathered until the fire
destroyed us I'm speechless
[Applause]
this is the first Sunday mass since the
fire
Mercy for those who died recovery for
the injured and patience for the victims
families those are the prayers of the
people gathered here
I can't imagine there'd be any more
celebrations in hamdania after what
happened but we pray not only for the
victims and their families but also for
the seemingly Everlasting pain to be
alleviated and for those unaccounted for
to be found
the death is of so many people including
children has angered and shocked many
here
foreign
church leaders want forgiveness for
everyone
we've asked the almighty to bestow his
grace and patience on us all we pray
that we can live in peace and stability
may the Lord protect the Iraqi people
and guide their leaders to the right
path families are now torn apart
some have lost several close relatives
worshipers here including some of the
victims families friends and neighbors
pray that such an incident will not
happen again in the town
they're demanding justice but say masses
and prayers like this are the only
Israelis they have for now
the loss is unbearable to have what was
supposed to be a happy event a wedding
turn into sorrow in a matter of seconds
forensic examinations are underway to
identify dozens of bodies
and bring closures to their families
while the church is likely to witness
more grieving more tears and more
prayers
foreign
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera